North East Derbyshire. A place where bustling
market towns meet rural beauty. All just a stone's
throw from the Peak District National Park and the
nearby cities of Sheffield Nottingham and Derby.
North East Derbyshire District Council is one
which listens and strives to do the best for
its residents and businesses, working with
them to make informed important decisions
which aim to improve the quality of lives and
help us grow together. We pride ourselves in
going above and beyond from emptying your
bins from rain or shine to offering support
helping local and independent businesses thrive
we're here for you. We run four fantastic leisure
centres in the district which are important
hubs for local communities in Dronfield,
Eckington, Killamarsh and Clay Cross perfect
for an early morning swim or an evening cycle.
We work closely with you - our communities - to
combat littering and fly-tipping taking strong
action against offenders and providing vital
funding to community groups and school projects.
Our resources can help new entrepreneurs start
up their own business helping them gain access
to vital funds and resources. North East
Derbyshire could be the perfect place for
large-scale businesses to relocate to with its
great road and rail links to nearby major cities.
And that's not all. We are passionate about
helping you gain employment and providing the
training you need to have a successful career
by offering a tailored, bespoke service to help
each and every one of our residents succeed moving
forward. We're continuing to enhance our digital
presence making ourselves more accessible online
so you can access the services you need when it's
convenient for you. We're making positive changes
to local areas building affordable housing for our
families and seeking out new leisure opportunities
brought to you by the £24.1m towns fund deal.
We'll continue to work closely with partners to
deliver a healthier more sustainable future for us
all. We care about our planet. We're implementing
our climate change strategy as we seek to be a
carbon neutral authority by 2030. We will help
you and your home become more energy efficient
through a number of green and sustainable schemes
saving you money in the process, however you may
work interact or contact us via email telephone
or seeing us in person - we're here for you
We live and work in a beautiful district. Let's
enjoy it, protect it, and work together. We are
North East Derbyshire District Council an
inclusive accessible and innovative council
breaking the mold and one which
prides itself on being there for you
our North East Derbyshire the
gateway to the country and city